- Today, we're gonna talk
about time management hacks
in law school.
There's absolutely no
substitute for hard work
in law school, but I can
recommend a few things
that will save you a hell of a lot of time
to work smarter instead of harder.
So stay tuned.
So let's talk about time
management hacks for law school,
things that will help
you save a huge amount
of time so that you can do the
things that will really help
on the final exam and
get you better grades
at the end of the semester.
So we want to cut out all
the busy work possible.
The first time saving tip
that I would recommend
is to get prior outlines.
Get old outlines that
are specifically tailored
for your professor.
You can talk to upperclassmen
who have had your professor before.
Or you can go to OutlineDepot.com.
OutlineDepot.com is great.
I have no affiliation with them,
but it's a great website where
if you upload one outline,
you're allowed to get a credit to download
someone else's outline.
And because so many people
have uploaded outlines
to their database, odds
are they're going to have
a prior outline for
your specific professor
in the class that you're taking.
So I would recommend getting
a handful of outlines
for your specific professor
so that you can use those
as a template to make your own outlines.
It's no substitute for putting in the time
learning the law, but it can
provide a great foundation
that you can add or subtract to.
It's the beginning of the
process that you can use
to save a lot of time instead
of doing it from scratch.
By the same token, use commercial
outlines and case briefs.
Things like Emanuel's for contracts.
There are commercial outlines
in just about any class
that you can think of.
They will save you a huge amount of time
in learning the substantive law.
And recently there have been
a preponderance of websites
and databases out there
that will case brief
every single case you could
possibly come across for you.
It can save you a huge amount of time.
We don't advocate doing any case briefs.
We think they're a waste of time.
But it's great to look
at other case briefs
to provide a foundation
before you read the case.
It's great to understand
what the general idea
of the case is before you
dig into your case book
and read the case yourself.
Tip number three: use Westlaw.
Westlaw is great.
You will use it all the time in practice,
either Westlaw or LexisNexis.
So you might as well get
familiar with it in law school.
And one of the great
things that you can do is
if you don't want to go the
commercial case brief route,
things like Quimbee for example,
you could use Westlaw to look up the case
that your professor wants you to read.
Even if the case is
old, Westlaw has an army
of reference attorneys that
summarize every single case.
You could just read
through the West head notes
and get a good idea of
what the case is about.
And it probably summarizes
the exact rule of law
that you're gonna need to
learn for the final exam.
So don't be afraid to use Westlaw.
It's not cheating.
It's a great way to practice something
that you're gonna use all
the time in researching
in the real world.
Tip number four: outline from day one.
This is controversial.
A lot of people wait until
the very last few weeks
of the semester before they outline.
I thing that's a horrible mistake.
If you outline every single weekend,
you synthesize all of the substantive law,
your notes with your commercial outlines,
and you put it into a
form that you understand.
You get that work done ahead of time,
it gives you so much more time
at the end of the semester
to do practice exams,
to memorize the black letter law
that you're going to
use on the final exams.
It's a huge advantage.
It saves you a huge amount of time
and creates more study time
at the end of the semester.
Tip number five: take a
course on law school essays.
There are clear strategies
for issue spotting exams
that you can use on any
class whether it's an exam
for contracts, or con law,
or torts, or whatever.
Standard strategies will work
on any issue spotting exam.
Legal Eagle has a course and
there are others out there
that are also very good.
It saves you a huge amount
of time because you can learn
to take law school essays yourself.
But you have to take a
number of practice exams.
And often, professors only give
you so many practice exams.
So it can save you a huge amount of time
to learn the strategies
up front so you don't have
to brute force your way
through a huge number
of practice exams.
Because they take hours
and hours to get through
every single practice exam.
If you learn the strategies
and start taking practice exams
at least halfway through the semester
long before everyone else
starts taking practice exams,
you will be miles ahead by the time
the study period rolls around.
And you will save a huge amount of time
before you have to take
your first final exam.
So remember, you can learn the strategies
that go into an issue
spotting exam the same way
that you learn the strategies
for reading comprehension
and logic games in LSAT.
And if you learn those strategies
and you start taking
practice exams sooner,
it will save you a huge amount of time
and you will be ready for your final exams
much earlier than everybody else.
And when you're graded on the
curve, that's what matters:
being better than everybody else.
So if you like this
video, please click like
and subscribe for more
law school crushing tips.
And also please download our checklist
that will help you hack
your way through law school
and save a huge amount of time.
So thanks for stopping by from
everyone here at Legal Eagle.